[Applause]
all right well everyone our next guest
is a little shy if anyone in the
audience has any twin blades or winged
spears talking to you reggie i'm gonna
ask that you please put those away for
now um let's let's bring him out he's a
little shy but look everybody it's it's
my pot friend
come on out pot friend
great to see you you should put a bow
tie on or something come on out pop
friend don't be shy uh
looks like he's got a a note or
something you got a note there pot
friend yeah all right
let's see
see what this note says thanks pot
friend
good evening
please enjoy my gift
a new trailer for eldon ring
i guess we've got another world premiere
trailer thanks buddy let's check it out
[Music]
it happened an age ago
but when i recall i see it true
on a night of wintry fog
the rule of death was stolen
and the demigods began to fall
starting with godwin the
golden queen america was driven to the
brink
the chatrin ensued a wall that wrought
only darkness
the elder ring was broken
but by whom
and why
what could the demigods ever hope to win
by boring
the conqueror of the stars
general time
and the blade of mickeleh melania vii
these two were the mightiest to remain
and locked horns
[Music]
but there would be no victor
[Music]
and so we inhabit a fractured world
awaiting the arrival of the eldenborn
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
you